[Music]
this morning on the dish a food trip to
the other side of the world
leah cohen is a former top chef
contestant who grew up in the u.s but
worked and lived in southeast asia
to pursue her cooking passions after
returning she opened pig and
cow a hugely successful restaurant here
in new york city
now she's out with a cookbook lemongrass
and lime a tribute to her parents
and a guide for home chefs who crave big
bold flavors
it's coconuts time yes uh
have you ever made fresh coconut milk i
have not okay
really i like using a cleaver because it
has a nice weight to it
and the exterior of this coconut is very
hard so you want something heavy to kind
of crack through it
there is nothing better than starting a
dish segment with coconuts and cleavers
so you just want to hit it hard and then
it's going to start cracking
but before we get too far with homemade
coconut milk
leah cohen wants us to know this cooking
thai food at home
or southeast asian food in general does
not have to be intimidating
yes they're often big very spicy flavors
so start with something simple like
chicken adobo every filipino is
judged on their adobo whether it's
chicken or
pork every adobo has these five basic
ingredients
soy sauce vinegar black pepper garlic
and bay leaves
get a little more adventurous and move
to papaya salad with long beans and
dried shrimp
or mussels in a pineapple curry broth
never mind these ridiculous
ricotta donuts it's not like super
traditional
by any means i don't normally have
ricotta cheese in southeast asia
all of the dishes are found in cohen's
homage to southeast asian cuisine
lemongrass and lime especially during
these times we can't necessarily
travel right now so if i could make them
feel like you know they're in these
countries
that was the goal of the photos in the
cookbook cohen's mother is from the
philippines
but leah's ascension to star chef was
hardly
you grew up the daughter of two dentists
they have great teeth most people in my
family uh went the
doctor dentist route aside from me and
my brother
but they're like i want to say like 10
dentists in the family
it was definitely um the
path less chosen being a chef no one in
my family
really was a professional cook my
grandmother
was a home economics teacher so i guess
that's kind of
maybe where i got you know the cooking
bug
why southeast asian cuisine for you i
just
found the food so fascinating and the
flavors
so bold and uh intimidating at the same
time
i felt connected to that part of the
world
i like the way you talk about breakfast
in the book yeah and that it's such a
different there's
breakfast such a different concept in
southeast asia than it is here
there are not specific dishes that you
would necessarily
eat just for breakfast like we think of
cereal and all that stuff
but in the philippines for example they
eat like rice dried fish
soup there is no real rules necessarily
for breakfast although i tried to make
more breakfasty brunchy items for that
chapter
also in the book lumpia shanghai olympia
olympia yeah and i'm dipping this in
this is a sweet chili sauce so it's a
little sweet
savory it's not spicy at all
perfect thank you and the bangkok
fire made with chili-infused whiskey
cheers
cheers
oh yeah that does have heat but for the
moment
back to the coconuts when you pick one
you want it to
feel heavy that means that there is a
lot of liquid inside and that will
make more coconut milk coconut milk
sounded great to us
so cohen i think you can do it let us
take a whack at it yeah
perfect you're a pro look at that see
it felt aggressive yeah it's a good way
to get your anger out i think
in a good way yeah totally it's
therapeutic you know
that may be something we all need in
these times
cohen's restaurant in new york city pig
and cow
is open during the pandemic but for
takeout only
she hopes her cookbook will inspire
people to make some outside of the box
creations at home that they might not
try otherwise
though for cohen this accomplishment is
bittersweet
i was really struck by the dedication in
your book
yeah so unfortunately um
in april i lost my father to covid
and so i was able just in time to change
my dedication because originally it was
dedicated to my son
but my father was my biggest fan
and so i wanted to make sure that
everyone knew
um how proud i was of him just like they
knew how proud he was of me
so can you talk about his unconditional
love yeah he was
probably the most positive person i've
ever met
he like knew the secret to life he
really just enjoyed life he knew how to
push people
to do great things without being overly
annoying and on top of you
i love the way she talked about her dad
yeah yeah yeah you were choked up too
i i was i mean it it it's emotional um
and
we thank her for talking about all of
that and we thank her
for the coconut lesson i mean he didn't
bring us i
chili-infused whiskey yeah spicy good
we'll have some after the show